wait so what happened what did you say
on I just put three pictures three
pictures sama-sama how are you good
how'd you guys how'd you guys find this
do you really want to know
yeah Instagram what I put out
yeah what other restaurants and you
figured it out we went on Google Maps
every single restaurant on the street
and I saw the blue lighting and the
drops we found you yeah I'm impressed
baby good [ __ ] be persistent
oh sweet so we're done we was somewhere
on Syria
he noticed our VP building actually take
this way to go to work every day so and
we live down the street there man so
awesome we have to come Hey all right
yeah how are you I was the one over here
I saw your Greyhound picture that's
[ __ ] crazy man where are you coming
from
I'm coming from what to do and how far
away is that it's like two hours orna
bus oh all right
I run a small startup so I thought I had
to come here thank you
hey man how are you nice to meet you man
thank can't even get a chance to go to
the conference congratulations awesome
hey man I don't know awesome
well cool you want a quick photo I know
you guys were waiting yes I need to get
back into my meeting I'm actually I
actually did post this stuff just now
but I'm going I'm going back in for at
least 15 minutes and then I'll go check
I would feel like in 15 minutes maybe
somebody'll show up yeah I'm always in
this and I never get tired of it then is
it enough to attract to invest and when
do you know you shouldn't take money out
of your existing business to put on
another one that's a tough question
take it again right I want to kill Rick
it's tough man like I I didn't invest in
uber in the angel round because I was
tired of investing in everything and it
cost me four hundred million dollars so
there's no right there's no right answer
right like that's got to feel it you got
to feel it I'm not gonna be able to
answer that for you
like but you can't invest everything if
I invested in everything that ever was
pitched me I'd be [ __ ] out of I'd be
homeless thank you thanks for all of you
coming yeah Gary I'm Marty Marty son how
do I say thank you you and Casey from
New York have inspired me I'm sure a lot
of people here thank you guys
beyond these be real be honest and just
work hard and I just can't thank you
enough for that
thank you guys have one question yep as
a hustler is it okay to take a day off
every week of course I take I take four
I take four hours off every Sunday in
the fall yeah of course I mean look my
big thing and I think it's good to have
you guys here for clarity I'm not so
worried if you take four days off I'm
just worried about what you do when
you're on
like I always tell people like I want
people like one thing that's why I did
the Arianna Huffington episode I want
people to sleep like I sleep like sleep
is important I sleep five or six or
seven hours not one or two like people
get caught up in like the romantic point
of view of these things like you could
take ten I took two weeks off in August
just now is a lot of you guys know like
first of all we're all different I have
a lot of natural energy some people my
brother has some of you may may know if
you read what he wrote like when he left
Boehner AJ's aren't hey AJ has Crohn's
disease right which trains him so he
can't work that way so I think you know
the way I do it or Casey ER this guy
like we're all different the punch line
though is if you're complaining and you
aren't working as hard as you possibly
can that's the problem like complaining
that you're not getting yours or it
hasn't happened and having enough time
to play pokemon go or Madden or watch
house of cards that's a problem but if
you're [ __ ] grinding and you need a
day to be with your boyfriend or
girlfriend or your family or just a
[ __ ] veg out that's fine
of course that's fine and most
importantly Who am I to say everybody's
got to do that my big thing is one thing
I haven't done a good job of that I've
been talking to d-roc and Tim about is a
lot more of the things that I want to do
is like if you complain and then go into
my rant like I don't know like I have
friends that make $42,000 a year work
9:00 to 5:00 and our [ __ ] pumped
they're the last people that I'm talking
to like they're happy but for so many
people like why so many of you are here
like you know like if you're hungry for
something I hope you understand that if
you're hungry they're like have this or
have great [ __ ] or you're gonna buy the
the maple leafs or talk [ __ ] like that
like you have the [ __ ] work I'm a
digital first of all your content is
awesome to the point where I watch it
every day my dream buddy right
but that's like--that's so i'm a digital
strategy whole online presence and I
help businesses get business results
with Catalan presence what I struggle
with is how to scale but also do I do I
specialize because I'm a generalist by
nature and I'm fascinated by social
search like the whole gamut of content
then that's what you should do right
just because somebody else has had a
success in going deep in something like
I continue to invest in things and like
I'm crazy and start up [ __ ] randomly
like because you've got to reverse
engineer yourself like just cuz somebody
said I don't believe that also know how
you function like I know that 30% of
[ __ ] I do is gonna fail and I'm gonna
lose money and waste time but I need to
do that to make the other 70% go because
I can't just concentrate and go deep I
need to get my entrepreneurial nut off
you know and so like that's just the way
it's gonna be and the net score of my 7
be working and throwing money and time
in the trash on the 30 is going to be
greater than other people's hundred
because that's how I function [ __ ] go
do it go yeah can you guys do me a favor
cuz I have to go to something else at
some point because there's so many of
you why don't we do like pictures and
signatures real fast and then over wants
to hang and like have deep [ __ ]
philosophical thesis is
yes got it I'll hang for that too in the
world when nobody's doing it how do you
convince customers to actually start
your commerce and get into it it's hard
I mean what guys can you get let this
guy through yeah you don't you can't
convince people no you've got to
basically just ask everybody and then
have somebody break through because
there's so much someone's complaining I
gather competitors you get it no she can
provide something so much better you get
it again yeah you just got it what too
many people do is try to spend too much
time it's kind of like what I'm trying
to do right now instead of answering
every question let me just get to as
many people spot and then too many
people they sell they want to like go so
deep and meanwhile there's so much else
to be done I think one of the biggest
reasons I'm a good salesman is I'm never
interested in convincing anybody I've
always sold things that nobody believed
in e-commerce in 1996 social media in
2006 people didn't believe in it I just
didn't care I had no time for you to
like convince you my whole punch line
was always like cool I'll see you in
2016 you know my biggest strength what
is your biggest ring you're asking me
what your biggest raise I'd probably say
[ __ ] tenacity good how do you
separate your personal brand versus your
external brand so to give you an example
are try your mark your China promote a
personal brand like yourself like you
have vaynermedia yes if Gary Vaynerchuk
yes how do you distinguish the two how
do you keep them separate without trying
to get them intertwined
I don't worry about it whatsoever people
overthink that [ __ ] all the time like
vaynermedia is a company it has 700
employees like if somebody's confused
and sometimes they are a CMO of a
company a big company will come in and
say hey I want you I'm like there's no
me I'm not for sale there's vaynermedia
you'll have Rick and Steve and soon
and Carla and that's it right you know
what I mean so I just explained it when
it matters
awesome you buying the dress one day man
I'm not worried about ways thank you oh
man yeah preciate hi are you question
yeah who do you go to your Jews when
you're dealing with the parent going
with the depression you have to spend
time with them you don't want to abandon
them what I did the first 10 years of
Wine Library what people don't know is
how much time I spent like with my dad
and like I get it
the answer is I don't know like for me
to answer that question for you it's
just inappropriate because it's such a
challenge what I will say is this you
don't and this is what kind of changed
my behavior you're gonna regret it so
much and you're gonna take it out on
them doesn't course is insurance you're
gonna wake up at 50 60 and 70 and blame
the parent for the time that they took
up where you didn't do your thing and
you're gonna eventually make that
relationship worse so what I did was I
chipped away at it well my ones that I
suspend feels today this [ __ ] office
and being a psychiatrist became - and it
became an hour and a half you're gonna
have to figure that out because either
you're living your life for yourself
you're living it for somebody else and
it's and it's you know I'm saying that
very empathetically cuz we all have
different situations but it's just black
and white there's no there's nothing I
can tell you other than you're gonna
wake up in 30 years and you're gonna
blame everything that you did not
accomplish on them for taking up all
that time I think so I think so because
I don't think you have to fully abandon
them but you need to find you need to
make sure that the cadence of the amount
of hours you put in isn't too great you
know and you also have your whole life
to live yeah like I don't know what your
family situation is but like
you know I look at like what's my
responsibility to my children versus my
parents to myself to my spout like
there's a lot of variables yeah what you
did today the 50 dozen I live in a pinch
me like a lot of people tell me like for
me that's like motivation that's another
but never mind
you can take the picture while I know
other people you judge get a shot but
like yeah my whole life I worked three
jobs they're pushing buggies and follow
that inch ever so you're doing that I
want to get in touch with James he's on
Twitter he's like we could see him good
luck to you and students good luck man
all right nice to meet you man to me yes
there well what's your name man Martin
ma I had a quick question I'm good okay
I'm a music producer I talk about a year
ago Bach crush it hustle my ass off
twenty-two thousand subscribers on
YouTube man thanks to you too Fred
I got you thing thanks to you you
listened straight up man like I'm
regionally ceiling or it's like I'm
trying to get my beats major artists but
it's so hard right like my audience
isn't even right I feel like I have
talent I could be working with Jay Cole
fat you all those guys 20,000
subscribers this is like this it's hard
to get in contact
it's got to be patient how would you
how'd you ever got anything Cole I'm
elements grana cold emailing [ __ ] work
yeah if they like your [ __ ] people are
looking for beats always and no only all
the points all all the guys all the guys
on top and I know a lot of them they'll
always spec listen
sure because their game is finding the
next [ __ ] so no matter how big they are
you just have to hustle and step up on
social hit them up in here yeah taking
on like social mission stuff at the
Center for social innovation with a lot
of Mars going on how do you see as a
social entrepreneur taking on that
market thanks man
meaning social cause yeah like social
cause on entrepreneurship they're like
how how kind bar did it so I think most
of those companies are straight full of
[ __ ] and use I'm being serious
I think all the people that followed
time shoes and we're like oh if you buy
one hat I give some kid and [ __ ]
Uganda a hat and then they mark up the
hats enough to pay for the give are
straight [ __ ] faces so I think I think
that I think that social good is great
and people should do it and I actually
don't think there's any
difference in marketing a company that's
got good DNA versus a company that's
just in it for the dollar I genuinely
don't believe that kind bar has any
fundamental different marketing strategy
then Snickers the difference is that if
they're smart and they get their story
in front of people that give a [ __ ]
about what kind mard talks about it
becomes a variable to what they can sell
but the strategy at the North Star is
not different what they're saying is
different I saw you I came out yes
Facebook is substantially bigger and has
more upside than YouTube yeah let's do
it fast okay hurry this guy's gonna run
you over
bye guys thank you thanks for coming out
guys thank you
[Music]